[Music]
all right let's go to kevin in los
angeles hi kevin welcome to the ramsey
show
thanks dave uh just a quick question
when choosing a mutual fund how much
weight should i give ratings from
websites like morningstar.com so for
instance i'm i was looking at two
different mutual funds and their
performance over the past 10 years one
of them looked like it had been doing
slightly better than the other but
morningstar gave it three stars where
the other had five stars should i factor
that in when choosing
morningstar's rating is risk adjusted
and so they're p they're pulling up the
beta the volatility of the fund
uh and adjusting on that probably that's
how they used to do it i haven't
subscribed to them in a long time
uh when i was back back when i was in
the business and then when i first
started on the radio i kept morningstar
on my computer before there was an
internet
we used to get cd rom updates quarterly
on them and uh so they're an old rating
system they've been rating mutual funds
a long time but if i remember correctly
they're risk adjusted and that may
explain it if you'll go pull the what's
called the beta the beta is the
statistical measure of risk and you'll
probably find that three star has a
higher beta that to get to a slightly
better rate of return it went through
higher peaks and lower valleys
does that make sense to you
yeah that doesn't make sense i'm
guessing but i'm guessing but i'll bet
you that's what you find
yeah it looked like the other things
that were factoring in were things like
how often the fund manager shifted and
stuff like that so like not just
volatility in the market of the fund but
like the volatility of the management of
the funds that wouldn't they would they
would look at that as well that does
make sense so it could be that in
addition to the beta now here's the
thing uh if you're looking at fund
volatility based on management there's
uh
more and more of the funds have gone to
a team
management style rather than a singular
rock star manager
that way they're not as dependent on
that one guy
for their future returns in other words
if you had a history of 10 years of
great returns and it was a rockstar
manager model not a team model managing
it and the rockstar guy leaves well the
track record kind of leaves with him
right
but if you've got a team model and two
of the 15 people running the fund
uh that are the brains causing the
return to happen over the last 10 years
leave well you're probably can say
that that history is probably valid for
projecting into the future common sense
wise anyway
and so a lot of the funds have gone away
from rockstar managers for that reason
and they've gone to team management
because that validates their
their historical returns that way into
the future and can project them into the
future but you just look at that i
honestly i mean i'll glance at that kind
of stuff i am mainly looking at the
track record and is there some reason
that the track record isn't valid
because the whole team left or there's a
complete turnover in style or a
philosophy shift in the management or
something like that unless there's
something that invalidates the track
record
i'm spending like 85 of my issue when
i'm picking a fund on track record
i'll look at the volatility i look at
the other stuff i look at the expense
ratios i look at all the other stuff but
it's a very small percentage of how much
time i spend
on that kind of thing and kevin i'll
tell you one other thing the fact that
you're asking these questions means
you're going to win and here's let me
give you the reason why
there's a a group of actuarial nerds
that studies retirement stuff um and
it's like 17 initials i can't remember
the name of it but i was looking at one
of their studies not long ago
and they found that 78
of the
predictive
reason for someone
becoming wealthy using an investment
is
savings rate
now let me translate that what that
means is 78 percent of the way you can
predict whether someone makes a bunch of
money in an investment is if they
actually invest
that's what that means no
how expensive was that study
geez and the point being though that
this group of nerds figured out that
you know this nuanced stuff of a beta or
an expense ratio
or team versus rockstar doesn't matter
put money into a retirement just will
freaking do it
you're just like gonna win okay i mean
compared to the people who over analyze
and don't do anything
right and so you don't get caught up in
paralysis of the analysis kevin get er
done baby that's the moral of the story
so i spend a certain amount of time in
looking at this stuff and if one of them
starts tanking on me i may move it but
i'm just putting it in there yeah when
in doubt when in doubt swing the bat or
you ain't gonna hit the ball i mean this
is like rock it was just the funniest
thing i've read because cause people in
the business they all get mad at dave
ramsey because he's too primitive and he
doesn't actually understand doesn't have
the intellect to grasp all of the
nuances of the investing world
yeah obviously i don't uh but but you
know and so but the truth is 78 has to
do with whether you actually did it
i saw that the other day someone was
asking some some fitness people what's
the best workout what's the best workout
and finally one guy snapped and said
anyone that you will do that's the best
one the one you don't quit keep doing it
the one that you don't quit doing get in
the game yeah
this is some genius advice we're doling
out here man